a lot of my work is on how we need uh
Viewpoint diversity we need people to
challenge us to make us smarter and I
think this format rather than a formal
debate to to bring people who been
writing about this together in a in a
collegial way who probably are going to
take opposite views on many things I
think is a productive and and really
enjoyable uh format so thank you to IQ
squared and to all of you for coming out
tonight um the there are two related
problems that have uh that have sort of
flooded into the United States were
become very visible in the last 3 or
four years they weren't really visible
before then uh so I'll just very briefly
State them and that I hope we'll set us
up for a discussion uh the first is that
we have um I'd say A Mental Health
crisis for boys and a mental health
catastrophe for girls what I mean by
that is that rates of anxiety and
depression were fairly stable uh in the
early from 2000 to 2010 and then they
begin Rising very sharply um for boys
rates of major depression are up about
30% for girls they're up about 40% some
people say this is just self-report it's
not real um but rates of hospital
admission for self harm are up in the
same way for girls not for boys though
um for suicide in the United States
suicide for teenage boys is up
25% from the first decade of the century
if you look at the rise to the last two
or three years 25% increase for girls
it's 70% 70 percent increase I just
looked at the numbers for the UK on my
way over here the guardian has had a lot
of really good coverage of the various
studies that have come out it's the
exact same thing you too have no rise at
all in Hospital admissions for boys boys
are not cutting themselves more but your
girls are going to the hospital much
more because they cut their bodies and
are bleeding um you also have even
though the suicide rate I think it was
in England and Wales even though that
suicide rate is going down to Historic
levels overall the rate for teenage
girls has reached its highest level ever
you also have about a 60 or 65% increase
in in completed suicides for English uh
English girls English and Welsh girls so
there's a mental health catastrophe
going on uh we don't really know what
causes it but the best the the most
likely explanations are the combination
of social media which is much harder on
girls than boys and the vast vast
overprotection that we in the United
States um we decided to stop letting our
kids out to tell them the world is
dangerous to tell them that if they're
ever not watched by an adult they will
be abducted we started telling them this
in the 1980s and especially in the 1990s
just as our crime rate was plummeting we
taught them that life is so dangerous
that they shouldn't be allowed outside
we deprive them of free play so we don't
know for sure but we have a mental
health crisis it begins with kids born
in
1995 we call them gen Z or gen Zed you
would say or the or I for the internet
generation so so when this generation
arrives on campus in the United States
that's around age 18 they come to the
university so in 19 in 2013 they first
the first members of of j z J Zed come
to campus and that's when all of these
things start none of us had heard of
these terms practically but by 2014 in a
few schools students were asking for
protections from words books speakers
ideas they were treating them as though
they were dangerous of course students
can protest have protested words books
speakers and ideas but they never before
said if this is presented if this person
comes I or someone will be traumatized
harmed damaged this was new we call this
in the book Greg lukanov and I call it
um safetyism the the worship of safety
the the the the view of the world as
safe versus dangerous Americans now
Young Americans talk about emotional
safety we used to call it emotional
discomfort Socrates reveled in creating
emotional discomfort on the way to to
learning um many of us are are reluctant
to do that now because if I create
emotional discomfort in my students they
might take that as that they're unsafe
and there's a number to call there's an
email to call to report me even from
class they can report me if they think
I've made them unsafe sorry Jonathan
just a com you have actually changed the
way you teach because of your own
worries yes I used to be a provocative
teacher I do not provoke anymore I just
play it straight I don't tell jokes I
don't show many videos because it's
happened to you personally yeah it
happens to a lot of people so we all
share stories when I started this in
2015 people thought that we were
exaggerating we're talk talking about a
few anecdotes because it was just
starting then now it is spread so far
that even though most students are fine
most students are not depressed they
want to learn they want to be exposed
but if you have a class of 300 students
you now have to teach to the most
sensitive student because any one of
them can report
you give us an example Le of how you
think this is manifesting itself on
campuses in the US what what have you
actually seen in concrete terms um so um
let's see what what have I seen so we're
very careful about exploring
hypotheses that could be taken as
contrary to received wisdom on
politically sensitive topics let's take
gender for example um so it's commonly
said that women earn 70% as much as men
um now that's a true fact in the United
States but that doesn't account for
hours worked or job picked if you
correct for those then we're up in the
'90s
um but it sounds better to say that
women are only paid 70% as much as men
for the same work any social scientist
knows that's a meaningless statistic
unless you equate for the kind of job in
the hours worked but I have seen social
scientists I've seen people say this
from the stage that women are only paid
70% as much and I've seen another social
scientist who know that that's not true
won't say anything because you don't
want to be called sexist you don't want
to be seen as challenging as somehow
denying or minimizing the problem and at
what point do you think the students
have the upper hand do you think that
students now dictate what is being
taught and what is being said on
campuses well you have to think about it
in terms of everybody is making a
calculation as they walk through we're
all caught in a mindfield we're all
walking through a world in which one
word we say and this is true for
everybody faculty students students
everybody one one word one thing you say
can be misreported or properly reported
on Twitter and it blows up into
something so this we're all stuck in
this and this is one of the reasons for
the Mental Health crisis um what we know
from surveys that we've conducted I I
run an organization or used to called
the heterodox Academy we've surveyed
students what we know is that they are
afraid to speak up in class many of them
report that they self- censor mostly
because they're afraid of other students
professors are mostly afraid of other
students the students again again Jen
Zed which grew up with the ability to
block things that they don't want block
people they don't want they're very
Adept at social media and so what's
happened is we don't trust each other um
we don't we it's very difficult for
professors to trust their students we
can trust most of them but that's not
enough you talk about antifragility now
I know that's a a phrase that goes up um
back to I think it's Nim talb isn't it
but you use this phrase antifragility to
talk about um an inability to have
resilience
yes this is the most important Concept
in the book and so I'll just I can lay
it out very quickly and if we if we all
if we have this on the table everything
else will make more sense so many things
this you know this glass is fragile and
if I drop it it will break and it won't
be better it will be broken and so we
give kids plastic cups because plastic
is resilient but if a kid drops a
plastic cup it doesn't get better there
are few things that need to be dropped
there are a few things that have to be
challenged in order to configure
themselves so the immune system is the
best example if you protect your kids
from bacteria and peanuts they will have
more autoimmune diseases and more likely
to have peanut allergies so the immune
system requires exposure to all sorts of
things well it turns out human beings
are antifragile human beings require we
we have to experience stress exclusion
teasing insults we have to experience
these things in small doses as kids to
set the social system that allows it to
wire itself up so that we can face
larger things by the time we're adults
in the United States now we have gone so
far towards protecting kids my daughter
when she was in third grade last year in
New York City Public Schools the girls
would form play groups on the playground
and hers was the kitty cat club and only
members of the kitty cat Club could hang
out in a certain place and so the
teacher said well you know she led them
through why we can't exclude people it's
wrong to exclude people well okay it's a
good discussion to have but if my
daughter would to go all the way through
schooling without having those
experiences when she gets to college she
won't be able to handle small things
that's what we think is happening kids
are actually anti-f fragile in the
United States and in Britain you've been
raising kids as though they're fragile
one of your head teachers recently
banned snowball fights because what if
someone gets hit in the eye if we
protect kids from small risks they don't
learn how to face larger risks and I'm
going to pick up with Ellena now um
lucky you you're you're our
representative I'm the snowflake you are
what do you prefer ien or Zen Jen Zed or
you choose oh you can call me a
snowflake if you want I reserve that for
my closest friends um let let's talk
about um the things that johnon has just
mentioned there stress
exclusion insults teasing do you feel
that those are areas that you should try
and protect young people from or did you
actually agree with most of what he said
well I think that um what Jonathan's
questions um Jonathan's questions um
attempt to essentially frame what is a
political problem as a problem that can
be reduced to and solved on the level of
like personal psychological robustness
and I think that movement is something
that is inherently flawed because what
we're facing now is a series of
overlapping political crises that
students on campuses cross the country
across the world are attempting to
develop Frameworks and epistemological
tactics and organizational tactics in
order to change
that and yes sometimes those look
uncomfortable to the kind of columnists
who are triggered enough to write an
article about how they don't have a
platform in a national
newspaper however um I think we're in
danger of um calling the people pointing
out the problem the problem we're in
danger of massively misdiagnosing the
real existential threats to our freedom
of speech which do exist but they don't
look like the very overblown handful of
cases of students on campus um overusing
tactics such as you know such as no
platforming or uh such as trigger
warnings they look like you know the
mass surveillance that's going on in our
society they look like um government
collecting data on Muslim Students
through uh prevent legislation they look
like the rise and Rise of the far right
who have explicitly mobilized around uh
things like shutting down free speech
they like to play victims and they like
to uh Spin A Narrative of martyrdom but
really um as the uh as Donald Trump has
shown us uh they have very little
interest in uh in the game that we think
they uh we think we're playing they have
no interest in civility they have no
interest in truth and they have no
interest in freedom of speech and what
we're in danger of doing here and I use
that word purposefully don't worry um is
having exactly the kind of concept creep
that you talk about in the book right
from freedom of speech as um freedom
from prosecution and freedom from harm
uh when you want voice your opinion to a
kind of freedom from consequence so what
we're expected is that powerful uh
speakers often uh powerful right in men
are um expected to be invited along to
very prestigious platforms to air their
views and uh not be challenged for it
and to me that's not uh that's not free
speech it's it's the exact opposite it's
using uh Free Speech uh it's using the
trappings of free speech to essentially
um protect people who are already
powerful from being challenged it's it's
essentially flying alive one of the most
most fundamental rights in our democracy
and you know wearing its dead skin so
Ellen I'm going to come in here because
um you're making these are really
important points I think now I wouldn't
have gone straight for no platforming
because I think that's probably exactly
the area that you think people push this
debate onto when it's if you like the
Pinnacle of it but since you are doing
that and you're talking about the far
right let's put some examples here um
the obvious one is Steve Bannon who was
in Oxford talking at the union um so in
that
situation you would not want Steve
Bannon anywhere near your
University well I think that um well
first of all my University um uh UCL
represent um has an in glorious history
of um things like uh white supremacist
conferences
Eugenics uh that kind of thing so the
university in and of itself isn't this
kind of like Sanctified Repository of uh
of knowledge that cannot be uh that is
apolitical and cannot be questioned they
are cultural institutions they live in
our society they are as flawed and as
struggling and as in evolution as the
rest of us right um but I think what we
need to uh need to understand is that
the university as a cultural institution
also conveys a stamp of
approval and that is a stamp of approval
that I don't want to see given to
someone who has no interest in uh
protecting free speech and um does pose
um and the politics that he has espoused
does pose an existential threat to you
know me and people like me I think what
we need to remember here is that free
speech is fundamentally important
because words have an
impact and to say that like we shouldn't
consider the impact of those words in a
limit number of cases such as the such
as the you know
fascism uh I think is ludicrous and I
think is an under analysis of the
importance of free
speech